تواجد حاليا على متن سفينه جلاله الملك
الرياض وهي الرحله الخامسه عشر منذ بدا
عمليات الاجلال من ميناء بورد سودان الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحري سوف ناخذكم في
جوله خاصه لشاشه العربيه كما نشاهد الان
بدات الانزال بعد ان وصلت هذه السفينه من
ميناء بورت سودان في رحله استغرقت قرابه
العشره الساعات من ميناء بورد سودان الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده على متن
هذه السفينه 220 راكبا من خمسه جنسيات
نتحدث عن 91 من الجنسيه الامريكيه و14
مواطن السعودي وثلاثه كنديين واثنان من
جنوب السودان وواحد من الجنسيه السودانيه
ايضا نتحدث انه اعداد كبيره تصل الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده منذ بدء عمليات
الاجلاء خلال الايام الماضيه نتحدث عن
ارقام اجماليه تجاوز الخمسه الاف
مواطن اجنبي من مئه جنسيه تم اجلائهم من
ميناء بورسودان الى جده عبر قاعه الملك
فيصل البحريه او حتى الى قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه وكذلك الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
اعداد كبيره من الرعايه يتوافدون يوما بعد
يوم وتزداد الاعداد بشكل ملحوظ مع عمليه
مع كل عمليه اجلاء ايضا المتوقع وصول
سفينه مدنيه تجاريه سعوديه على متنها
اعداد تلامس الفين شخص يوم
ظهر يوم غدا الان بدات عمليات الانزال
لهؤلاء الرعايه كما ذكرنا اعداد من
الرعايه بدو بعمليات النزول نتحدث عن
اوائل واطفال وكبار السن بمختلف الجنسيات
والاعمار يتم التعامل معهم وفق مستوى واحد
نتحدث انه في متعلق بعمليات الاجلاء
المستمره من قبل السلطات السعوديه لهؤلاء
الرعايه وسط حمايه
وعبر السفن القوات البحريه السعوديه
من ميناء بورت سوداني لقاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه يتواجد القنصل الامريكي على ارض
قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه لاستقبال الرعايه
وكذلك وجود عدد من السفراء وايضا من
القناص لاستقبال
لمده شهر واحد من قبل المديريه العامه
للجوازات نظرا لظرف الانساني الذي يعيش
هؤلاء
الصوت يتقطع قليلا سلطان
نعم اذا هذه
مباشره من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في
جده حيث مراسل عربيه سلطان السلمي ينقل
لكم الصوره وهناك رعايه كما تشاهدون
ينزلون من على متن السفينه الملك الرياض
قادمين الى جده تمهيدا لنقلهم الى بلادهم
في اطار جهود تبذلها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لاجلاء الرعايه من السودان هل
يسمعني سلطان الان بشكل احسن سلطان
نعم نعم كما نشاهد بدات عمليات الانزال
تتم عمليات الانزال بدءا باصحاب الحالات
الصحيه الطارئه الذي سوف تتعامل معهم
مركبات الاسعاف ويتم اجلاؤهم مباشره الى
اقرب مستشفى للتعامل مع هذه الحالات ومن
ثم النساء وكبار السن بعد ذلك بقيه الركاب
من الملفت وجود عدد من الاطفال على هذه
السفينه بشكل كبير جدا عكس خلاف او خلاف
السفن الاجلاء التي وصلت الى قاعه الملك
فيصل البحريه خلال الايام الماضي لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات